[Musique]
paris 8 millions d'habitants
l'une des villes du monde dont la
densité de population est la plus élevée
au kilomètre carré l'excessive densité
de la population de paris et sa banlieue
a fait de notre capitale un monstre où
il est de plus en plus difficile de
vivre un monstre qu'il est de plus en
plus difficile de rendre vivable on
reproche à paris d'être une ville
malsaine une ville sale chacun de nous
est responsable par négligences par
insouciance par inconscience de
l'insalubrité de notre capital qu'il
soit humain mécanique ou animale le
parisien est jugé négligent par son
voisin chacun est prêt arguments à
l'appui a dressé un véritable
réquisitoire
c'est dégoûtant c'est écoeurant je suis
écoeuré vous ne pouvez pas lâcher son
marché dans les crottes de chien les
aveugles avec leur canne tripote là
dedans les enfants tombent dedans c'est
ignoble
vous pouvez aller dans les quartiers
même des quartiers résidentiels c'est
une ont parié 5 dégoûtant il faut
empêcher surtout toutes ces digues bonne
forme avec leur cadeau de 200 fichiers
de ce premier cas faisant des saletés
sur les trottoirs vont se voit confronté
rigole en été des rigoles lui hurle
huysman tegra graisseuse et salle
dégoûtant et alors c'est plein de
vermine nous est obligé de vivre à paris
oui je suis obligée vtem parce que j'y
travaille
vous trouvez que l'airé pur non moi je
préfère la grande manne pour faire la
campagne je forçais de travail madame ça
fait longtemps que vous vivez à paris je
suis né est ce que vous trouvez que au
point de vue viennent ça a changé plutôt
comment qu'est-ce qui est pas propre
les rues
on fait passer ce que vous trouvez que
les conditions de vie à paris sont
saines
comment voulez vous qu'un spécial et où
l'herbicide actuellement et depuis très
longtemps est ce possible
vous pensez qu'on peut faire quelque
chose à ça la solution c'est pas moi que
ça répond il ya des savants pour ça et
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'on puisse
faire contre l'eire à paris où les
maisons par terre la bière radier de
faire des squares photo ec l'air est pur
que l'eau est bonne que les rues sont
propres ont toujours qu'est ce que vous
souhaiteriez c'est difficile à dire
c'est pas moi décider c'est au conseil
municipal d'octobre quoi vous avez
devant vous le nouveau règlement
sanitaire du département de la seine
c'est un document assez importants
puisqu'ils comportent environ 300 pages
quelles sont les idées directrices qui
ont présidé à la rédaction de ce
document les idées directrices procède
des modifications en matière d'hygiène
qui se sont produites surtout après la
guerre
surtout après la guerre parce que
le mode de vie des populations s'est
considérablement modifié à la suite de
la mécanisation et la suite de
l'accroissement des populations surtout
de la région parisienne où autrefois la
règlement régissait des populations ne
dépassant pas quelques millions
d'habitants tandis que maintenant vous
savez que la région parisienne latin 8,9
et on prévoit bientôt 12 millions
d'habitants
quelles sont les grandes têtes de
chapitres de ce nouveau règlement
sanitaire
bien sûr en tête de chapitre vise la
portée générale
je pense en particulier quelque chose
qui fera plaisir aux ménagères qui
doivent travailler le matin c'est
qu'elles peuvent battre leurs tapis
beaucoup plus tôt contre x d'autre part
ceux qui possèdent encore des animaux à
domicile on le droite les faire 20 quai
sur le trottoir à condition toutefois
que les besoins physiologiques de ces
animaux se satisfait dans les caniveaux
donc il sera possible que les voitures
automobiles leur en laisse l'accès du
point de vue collectif les choses sont
beaucoup plus sérieuses et beaucoup plus
vaste
en particulier le règlement sanitaire
ici renverse absolument les notions que
nous avions autrefois en matière
d'habitat c'est l'apparition des
immeubles tour ou des grands immeubles à
étages multiples et qui troublent
totalement nos conceptions en matière de
distribution d'eau et d'évacuation des
résidus intérieur des dix immeubles les
autres grands chapitres toucher les
problèmes qui se rapporte à l'hygiène
alimentaire et provisionnement des
ménagères tout le monde fait ch à une ou
deux fois par semaine et un cumul pour
les autres jours un certain nombre
d'aliments le plus souvent dans des
emballages dit perdu le problème type 2
dans ce genre c'est celui qui concerne
la viande hachée
monsieur est ce que vous savez quelles
sont les mesures qui vont vous être
imposée oui en premier il s'agit de
faire le bifteck lâché au fur et à
mesure et à la demande du client et il
ya une deuxième disposition qui vous
impose d'avoir un lavabo au coin de
votre magasin à portée des mains des
grisons cela va vous entendre il est
toujours dans les rivières bookeen
d'ailleurs j'en ai un et ça sert
beaucoup à chaque fois que le garçon
même on y va souvent monsieur vous
préparer des plats cuisinés c'est
d'ailleurs très appétissant mais quels
sont vos obligations en matière
d'hygiène pour votre personnel va mon
personnel est soumis tous les moyens d y
crée dicale par le ministère du travail
tous les mois ou deux mois en ce qui
concerne la pollution des eaux
le département de la seine qui est
parfaitement conscient de la nécessité
de lutter contre pollution
actuellement on triple la station
d'épuration d'achères et on la porte ce
fait à la dimension des grandes stations
qui existent dans le monde auprès des
métropoles c'est une action considérable
rendu financier comme aux pros du
technique en matière de pollution d'air
là aussi nous avons des exemples précis
puisque paris est couvert par deux zones
d'action spéciale au sein desquelles les
combustibles seront réglementés quant à
leur qualité et où les propriétaires
recevront des visites périodiques d'un
part d'agents spécialisés pour les
conseiller dans la marche ou la
surveillance de leurs chaufferie mais en
ce qui concerne la maladie la
propagation des maladies contagieuses
nous avons créé un service
d'intervention d'urgence doté de trois
estafette blanche pourvue d'appareils de
radio de façon à pouvoir les toucher
comme les ambulances de l'assistance
publique à travers paris il est bien
évident que nous n'avons pu traiter en
détail chacun des 150 articles de ce
règlement sanitaire il nous resterait à
évoquer entre autres le problème des
piscines le problème des pigeons celui
du gaz d'échappement des voitures et
bien d'autres encore
dans quelques jours le nouveau règlement
sanitaire entrera en vigueur
dûment agréé par le préfet de la seine
et le préfet de police
s'il vous arrive d'être en infraction
avant de penser à la menthe que vous
risquez réfléchissez à cette petite
phrase propreté partout santé pour tous
[Musique]